the Joe Rogan experience well I think we
can get into epidemiology and look at
that but I think we should definitely
hit protein because I think of everyone
watching that's the biggest myth and
it's we just sort of gripe and I think
we should definitely be 12 so I wanna
make sure would be 12 because one of the
things that you said that he disputed
was did it bring up that b12 quote that
you said was complete horseshit I can
read it out if you want dad please b12
is this in if you disagree with what you
were Deacon b12 isn't made I'll read the
whole thing and then so b12 isn't made
by animals it's made by bacteria these
animals consumed in the soil and water
just like with protein animals are only
the middlemen but for industrial farming
farming farm animals and humans could
get b12 by eating traces of dirt on
plant foods or by drinking water from
rivers or streams but now because
pesticides antibiotics and chlorine kill
the bacteria that produces vitamin even
finer moles have to be given b12
supplements and you said that's just all
false that's all just factually wrong so
first of all b12 is made by bacteria but
it's animals don't get it from consuming
the soil and water first of all you
misrepresented what I said so I said
it's made by bacteria that these animals
consume you went on to say that animals
didn't get bacteria from the soil that's
not what I said I said they'd get it
from the bacteria that they got from the
soil so you misrepresented what I said
you you made out the key claims you made
James is that a spot it was pot used to
be possible to get b12 by eating dirt or
on plant foods or out from drinking
water from rivers or streams I've still
have not seen convincing evidence that
okay so I was like 14 Jack Norris a
vegan diet ition has admitted as much in
his article and then even more relevant
than all of that is looking at b12
deficiency rates between vegans
vegetarians and omnivores in the
clinical literature like the the other
stuff is not really relevant until you
get community to the clinical can we
address each of your critiques then is
that okay yeah so first of all you said
there's zero evidence the b12 is fed to
cattle right
said that and so can I just first unit
because I said even farm animals can you
put up slide 44 please marry me I said
even farm animals have to be given b12
supplements that's what I said okay so
did you mean all farm animals okay so so
do you see that that is a screen cap
from the film that's a chicken and down
at the bottom there's the quote for the
poultry right so would you agree that
pigs and chickens and no I don't
disagree that they sometimes get b12 but
do those what about shellfish shellfish
are extremely high in b12 they're the
highest total non sequitur honestly
because the implication in the film was
the only reason you get b12 from eating
animal products is because they're given
b12 supplements so yeah are you a Ewing
certainly so you're really suggesting
that the like the population gets most
of its b12 from shellfish no okay I'm
saying that the claim that animals need
to take b12 supplements in order to have
b12 in their flesh so he's not think
chickens got it from it James why do you
think triggered it about the shellfish
was I never claimed chicken was a great
circle I said you I said in the film
even farm animals have to be complete
resins you said that it was absolutely
false everything that I said about b12
you said was absolutely false there's
also you talking about the people used
to be able to get it from consuming
vegetables right on it and that the
water is now because of pesticides and I
mean the water no longer has you claimed
that the same percentage of you you
picked one study that showed equal the
rates of deficiency are the huge amount
of literature that shows big differences
between vegans vegetarians and awful
deficient I know all of your critiques
because I've noted them and I've got a
point for each one so can I just go
children and then you can if you
disagree you can so could you just Jamie
could you brought to slide 45 and I know
rather than throw him off track going
about humans we'll get to that in a
second but that I mean b12 is just
commonly
two chickens in Europe we would agree
with that right yeah and and pigs and
lambs that feel that can't room and like
ruminants can create b12 in their gut
from the bacteria yeah okay yeah so but
you brought in travel by valves and
there ya know surely massage yeah that's
not yeah totally okay so super since you
brought up cattle you said that cattle
there's no evidence of cattle being fed
be twelve so if you bring up flight
forty-six vitamin b12 for sheep and
cattle it's what it says you said
there's no evidence so you said there's
no evidence so it's the left that just
so because people might not go to read
the small print well listen there's
people just listening as well twelve
injection for sheep and cattle there's
three different processors added to feed
on the left so it says a liquid
complemental complementary feeding stuff
containing the central trace elements
cobalt selenium twelve of b12 deficient
for us let's do two some soils and
cobalt which is of a lot of character so
now if you just go to slide 47 please
Jamie next slide okay this is the
largest supplier of animal feed or
supplements in the world okay on their
website young ruminants requires
supplemental vitamin b12 prior to full
room and development
they also say vitamin T was sometimes
administer enter early to incoming
feedlot cattle and also b12 by the way
has been shown to increase milk
production you said there was no
evidence that cattle are given b12 and
you said that all my statements were
absolutely false do you at least admit
that you were wrong there if I said that
at all this specifically that one
portion of the statement there's no
evidence to ever get b12 supplements
okay is it first of all when I made the
full statement this is what you first
said that's just all false that's all
just factually wrong and then later on
you said there's also zero evidence that
b12 is fed to cattle that is flat-out
wrong and I have just shown
is that fair I was right okay so we'll
get to another point because you were
wrong about many other things as well
okay so let's see so you agree that you
know it is fed to cattle so you want to
look at humans should I say there none
of the points that you brought up
they've been giving minerals and fee and
different things to the point if cattle
are deficient because they're in a
feedlot where they're not eating grass
not only that and that is the primary
reason it isn't only war because young
cows every piece of young cows that are
most likely we don't have been getting I
know you know meat b12 from animals do
you just do you dispute that the primary
source of b12 for human beings has been
eating animals and also fish and
shellfish in history
and I'm from revenge but where's the
evidence that the rivers and streams and
dirt has been a primary source I'm gonna
give it to you okay I think I came into
debt you think I made claims in the film
that I couldn't back up perhaps we did
we went over those in the last show yes
okay stick with the b12 sure okay so can
we just go to slide 48 so each health
concentration fluctuated between 100 so
this is in the levels of water in the
English Lake District if you want to go
to slide 49 the vegetables were
vegetables were eaten without being
carefully washed the strict vegetarians
who did not practice hand-washing or
vegetable cleaning may be untroubled by
vitamin b12 of division C and by the way
the there are retained vitamin D 12a
soil was adequate to prevent b12 - so
what you're essentially saying is that
we're dealing with b12 that was in soil
and land in water and that by the
chlorination and filtration systems that
we use today that's what's ruining the
water in the water does not want to know
which is a good thing yes but that also
takes out the b12 sure so he likes your
statement correct sir he was wrong again
that's not the consensus view that you
can get enough b12 from eating unwashed
didn't necessarily say that was the
consensus view what he said in the
statement was that the reason why we no
longer have b12 in the water and in the
soil is because the fact that they had
chlorines and pesticides and that seems
like there's evidence to back that so
again now people question did I spend a
thousand hours okay now that I'm giving
you the facts do you question that I
spent a thousand hours I've spent sent
another two thousand hours looking at
peer-reviewed research since then if you
say you have I don't have no reason to
disbelieve it's a lot of time it's a lot
of ten thousand hours a lot of time like
what was it Lane Lane Norton said that
you should probably have gotten a PhD I
think well I don't think that's the case
I think there's people a lot smarter
than me that are making these scientific
Matt that amount of hours of research
I've estimated that I've done conserved
estimate I've done since then about
three thousand hours because once I
started making the film and doing that
then I didn't anyway I believe you so
anywhere else so can I 12 analogues in
the soil that aren't absorbed and
utilize like true b12 okay do you think
can we admit the two things the things
that we've you touched on so far you you
got wrong absolutely that it's proven
that cattle do receive b12 under
whatever circumstances I don't know
whether it's because they're grass-fed
or grain fed I'm assuming they're
feedlot animals that don't get proper
nutrients from soil right don't get
proper New Yor getting these grain Feld
fed soybean fed cattle and they're just
pouring this dried out [ __ ] into a
bucket these animals are not grazing and
they're likely deficient in a lot of
different things okay
this also they've always been
supplementing their die with minerals
supplementing with vitamin that's the
funny people like oh well let's just
take the extreme end of plant-based
thought vegans right so people say all
vegans have to take a supplement well
guess what you're supplementing anyway
you're just doing it in the regular
eating that kind of 99% of the 97 to 99
yeah
so the vast majority so well you know
people are getting it you're
supplementing you're not just suddenly
b12 you've a son amending de in I'm
getting it from someone who supplements
it in the feed of the animals and then
you get it that was generally not in
grass-fed beef can you just admit that
you made instead about those things b12
in cattle and I mean you have a third
point so we had the b12 in cattle
you've had that the use of no average
you said there was zero evidence about
that you said there was no evidence
about being able to get it from water
and from dirt which again I proved to be
for you to be wrong and the third thing
you said I said that there's no evidence
that humans primarily got their b12 from
eating from soil and water with no no no
I didn't you're miss fret again he's
misrepresenting and he's wrong Joe
you've gotta admit but in this case well
it's clearly wrong about b12 being given
to cattle I mean we showed it says
before industrial farming farm animals
and humans could get b12 by eating
because of dirt on plant foods or
drinking water from rivers or streams
you don't think that people will get the
idea from hearing that that we never
needed to consume animal products to get
b12 and we don't also could we could get
plenty from eating corral so where is
the evidence for that other than the one
study that you showed there that that's
because most evidence raviga pnes it's
even vegan these are solder many these
are modern vegans right he's got two
things wrong in this because his
statement is essentially saying that the
reason why we don't get it today is
because of so the a third point you I
said this you took issue with my plan
okay and up to 39 percent of people
tested including meat eaters are low in
b12 as a result the best way for humans
to get enough b12 whether the animal
foods or not is simply take a supplement
then you said he
provide a reference for that so it's
hard to check but again it contradicts
you know mounds of evidence on b12
efficiency so can you bring up slide 50
please Jamie you said that I didn't
provide a reference okay but in the
bottom-left where we put all of the
reference was in however I made a claim
about the scientific research
well it's covered by the it'll go away
in a second okay okay
allegedly okay first of all there's the
reference you claimed we didn't have
reference would you admit that you were
wrong I missed that okay three times
wrong about b12 okay so can we just go
into your study sorry your e-book on b12
you basically said I don't know where
you got that study from your b12 ebook
opens with the exact same study so can
you put up slide 51 please Jamie okay
is that your ebook on the left yes okay
you round it up to 40 but I kept you at
39 okay
your lives being specific b12 deficiency
is far more common than most healthcare
practitioners and the general public
realized data from the Tufts University
Framingham Offspring study suggests that
40% of people between the age of 26 and
83 have plasma b12 levels in the low
normal range a range at which many
experienced neurological symptoms that
was the opening statement of your b12
ebook and you claimed that where you
couldn't find the evidence of that study
I no disagreement that b12 deficiency is
an issue I talked about that on my
website that's not that's not what you
said on the last time you want rows
podcast you said I don't know you didn't
provide a reference for that so it's
hard to jack but it contradicts the
evidence if that's not reflective of the
preponderance of evidence why did you
open your ebook with it it's not right
okay so there's two different issues
here one is do omnivores get b12
deficiency I do yes they do okay and 40
people tested in this study which is
where you reference right and there are
many I'm not saying this study is bad
but you say look at all of you said I
didn't provide a reference for you did
you do you write you're on ebooks by the
way I do and you don't remember that
study no I write
do you know how you have any idea how
many articles I've written over the
years right do you remember every study
from every article I don't know right
trainer and that's the thing do you not
feel like I'm a combative trainer you
yourself recognize that you're not a
nutrition expert right you said that at
the beginning I'm not a nutritionist I
have master's level training in
nutrition so I mean yeah so b12 is - is
that specifically me like master's level
training and nutrition price thank you
Joe well in California acupuncturist
have a four year master's program which
includes a lot of medical sciences and
nutrition research methodology etc
because we're considered primary care
providers in the state of California so
the training is a lot different than it
is in other places so there's the
question of can omnivores develop b12
deficiency yes they can if you go and
look at the rest of the ebook it's
because of things like SIBO that's
higher ranges you'll actually set higher
ranges of what would be considered
potentially deficient right you'll say
like three four hundred might be
deficient so that would mean that even
more people were deficient right now I'm
not arguing that vegans can be more
division omnivores
but can I just go to slide 52 can I go
to slide 52 so what is that what is the
question here if you're not arguing no
I'm just does not be more it's more
common I'm pointing out that you as that
is what clinically makes the difference
if someone is b12 deficient I get then
then Nathan I think I'm not prepared to
get to that I will get to that you said
that like the four or five claims that I
made about b12 or patently false I've
already pointed out three of the things
that you got wrong out of the five and
you were the one that like is
recommending and telling people what to
eat I am a combative strainer and my
facts in this case are this doesn't
change anything about the factors I'm
recommending no it doesn't what is
Israeli
is still that people get enough b12 and
that they are less likely to do that on
a vegetarian and vegan diet and there's
lots of studies showing that pork
cannon on of or developed b12 deficiency
absolutely I see it advances and nearly
all of the people that not the vast
majority no no no no I didn't say that
the vast majority of that forty percent
were meat eaters you referenced you
didn't reference this not only because
there are more meat-eaters in the
general motivation that has nothing to
do with the fact that beaters are not
efficient I'm not arguing where we've
got all of these studies about
homocysteine 9 out of 10 reviews that
have shown higher homocysteine levels
and vegans vegetarians this to the point
that he made last night I'll never get
the robot okay so when you reference the
Framingham study you didn't link to the
study you link to an article from the us
theory about the study and that study
said oddly the research has found nois
again this is the opening statement of
your e8 book references this study but
you felt you didn't mention this part
oddly the research has found no
association between plasma b12 levels
and meat poultry and fish intake even
though those foods supply the bulk of
b12 in the diet it's not because people
aren't eating enough meat to get that
b12 talk I said it's the vitamin isn't
getting absorbed so is that so this
backs up my claim that the safest way to
get b12 is to take a supplement now
Chris will just say 60 can I just finish
on this point no no you can retire on so
your claim was what people can just go
and get so you agree that so um you know
I would say that vegans that don't
supplement and omnivores there's a lot
more deficiency in vegans right like
it's a consistent nutrient of concern
that vegans should be cautious or by
universe accept is right yeah
so but that you even if you don't accept
the 40% number even though that you said
that I didn't say I didn't accept that
it doesn't matter whether you're
accepted or not it like you've even said
that like we should consider higher
levels b12 division so it remade even
more but doesn't that doesn't really
matter the point is that you are saying
that grows are going in this
they're saying the vitamins not getting
absorbed in that b12 also my point my
point was it's safer
just take a b12 supplement and for the
general population in the world that is
the best recommendation you'll say you
can go to your doctors and get a sixty
dollar blood test and test would be
twelve then you can decide whether you
need a supplement or not yeah stop you
guys both here why isn't it getting
absorbed if there is a higher level of
vitamin b12 and fish and there's other
factors that inhibit the absorption so
what does Evo is one yeah when likely
vegetables conditions but also in the
growth in the small intestine so so so
joke so basically um but we still have
the best safest way for everyone to get
b12 it's a good supplement well right
you say well you can just spend sixty
dollars and get a blood test you've got
to recognize in the world not everybody
can afford a facility okay so the safest
way to get b12 if whether you eat me or
not is to get take a b12 supplement we
know that is surest way let's just all
agree on that the surest way is the
surest way for sure but then when you've
got studies that show you know 11% of
omnivores have b12 depletion versus 77
percent of vegetarians and 92 percent of
vegans you know that's with using holo
Transco Ballymun which is a much more
sensitive marker b12 deficiency than
serum b12 which is really problematic
and then you have nine out of ten
comparisons of homocysteine that found
higher levels of homocysteine and
vegetarians and omnivores and higher
levels and vegans compared to
vegetarians and homocysteine is also
more sensitive marker than serum b12 so
there's four stages of b12 deficiency
and serum b12 will only go down out of
range in the fourth and final stage of
b12 deficiency so these other studies
that I shared on the last show we are
looking at holo transcript element which
was the most sensitive marker b12
depletion it's not technically the
deficiency at that point and then you
have homocysteine and methylmalonic acid
that are more sent less sensitive than
holo transcript element but more
sensitive than it's here in b12 okay
okay can you bring up slide 54 please
okay and I need to show you so not only
if you got all the facts wrong so far
about b12 or my claims you said that
they were all fault
and they weren't false by every claim
that I made so far was backed up by
science and you have admitted that you
made mistakes okay so this is your slide
this is your slide right this is because
this is how I can show these handpicking
these studies to make his claim you said
that 90% of vegans were deficient in
let's read what it says his b12
depletion among animal omnivores
vegetarians and vegans vegans now we got
to remember that most people are
probably listening versus water sorry
yeah okay so vegans 92 percent
it says 77 vegetarians 77 percent and
omnivores 11 percent for b12 depletion
but that study showed it was more like
40 percent of depletion even across the
board I'm not trying to compare the two
okay I'm just trying to say your case by
using the study is that 90 percent of
vegans are deficient in b12 and
omnivores an efficient okay whatever I'm
not trying to pick apart this study I
agree with the study okay okay can you
just go to the next slide please Chris
I think it's slide 55 okay this is from
the study okay this is from 16 years ago
by the way and a very small study from
16 years ago and this is why I show you
that he's hand picking the data that he
uses and this is where I go back to the
fact that it's about the interpretation
of the totality of evidence and you
can't really rely on something that's
not a nutrition expert hand picking
studies to suit their bias so in sub
this is what it said in subjects who did
not consume vitamins the levels were
what Chris said right 11 percent in
omnivores seven percent and so I would
agree like if you couldn't get b12
anywhere you should incorporate some
animal foods into your diet that okay
but let's look at some other studies so
slide 56 and I'm only choosing a few I'm
sure certainly they're in my favor
and I'm not saying that vegans don't
have lower b12 levels because some
people don't supplement right but it's
like you I'm showing that you
hand-picked a study from 16 years ago
slide 56 from this is for a new study
from 2018 with twice the sample size of
one to know people now know you should
have two b12 supplement the studied
markers indicate a generally sufficient
cobalamin status in the
of the diet preferences lacto-ovo
vegetarian or vegan slide 57 now this is
a study that looked at
runners in May of 2019 really current
and it feels like you might not have the
most current data because you said to me
in your email that you nutrition is only
one part of what you do and you have
lots of other things that you're doing
right so slide 57 this is comparing
vegans vegetarians and omnivores and
these are runners yeah and recreational
educational yeah all three groups showed
an adequate biomarker status of b12
related parameters and then flyed 58 it
would be and this one not only backs up
my point about vegans but also and
plant-based leaders but also that
supplement eaters are better so the
vitamin b12 status of supplement users
of vegans and omnivores who is higher
compared to the non supplement users and
a higher proportion of nonstop newses
had b12 parameters outside the reference
range you know they were low so again
that's more evidence that people it's a
good idea to supplement in general
because you just have higher levels and
after and consensus recommendations
after you get over 50 you have lower
incomes it's a water soluble vitamin
anyway yeah but after 50 you lose
intrinsic factor so you can't absorb as
much so it's not dangerous to have
higher levels so even a good thing to
supplement period right every single
thing that I said in the b12 payment is
true and backed up by so Jamie bringing
slide 59 for me if we're looking at
totality of evidence let's look at more
evidence totally but again I'm not
pointing those few studies out say
there's not more I'm saying that you
hadn't picked a study where we can pick
a study James there's many studies here
vitamins and I agree so we agree that
people on plant-based diets take vitamin
b12 actually said and we agree that most
people are getting their b12 supplement
in any way just indirectly through
animals fair enough fair enough if you
follow the diet that these animals were
on which is the most majority of people
and again
I would say look look if you want to eat
95% plants and you know how common it is
for them to supplement animal diet with
b12 is it a rare thing with cattle it's
lower because there's a lot of a lot but
much it's not that rare but it's lower
but it's not super rare because a lot of
soil is deficient in cobalt and cows
need to consume the cobalt to
manufacture the b12 in their in their
room so it's more of a side effect of
mineral and neutral or deflation also
but not for pigs and chickens and that
stuff so
vegans have higher homocysteine levels
than omnivores Donna attempt comparisons
found higher are homocysteine levels in
vegetarians and omnivores and higher
levels in vegans and vegetarians right a
blintz of hyper homocysteine you need
home assistant emia among vegetarians
may actually be higher than that among
non vegetarians already diagnosed with
heart disease so that's 9 of 10
comparisons that's not handpicking one
study that's 9 out of 10 comparisons
that have been done on this topic right
and the out like you said before we
shouldn't just look at the markers we
should look at these outcomes right
vegans and vegetarians with higher
homocysteine levels do not have
increased risk of cardiovascular disease
or diabetes or death from those or from
cancer I didn't make the claim that they
do we're talking about b12 and
homocysteine being a marker right and
I'm Chris I am showing that you picked a
study from 2016 which have a test very
small sample size that was nine out of
ten comparisons right there I am saying
that when you came to b12 all of the
statements that I made in the film were
true and you said that they were
patently false and you were wrong I
didn't Joe come on now listen I've come
in here correct right because I've come
in here and people saying oh what are
you gonna say to that debunk Chris did
not debunk the film he made
misrepresentations of our claims and he
got things factually wrong well he
certainly seems to have gotten it
factually wrong that animals
particularly cows are not given b12
supplements he certainly seems to have
gotten if
actually wrong that at least some of the
b12 that people would be able to get in
the past but I got from water and soil
and the Fortis people our division valve
and for the best way to get b12 is the
supplement so yes and every but you're
wrong
so so the thing is I have proven that he
got three or four things factually wrong
I love we 12 right and I am a combatives
instructor okay with that right I'm just
saying I'm putting myself down I
understand I'm not like a super
intelligent guy but you are so you are
very intelligent I've said that before
what you did is you did research on
these very important subjects when you
acquired a lot of data so I thought this
is what people do when they go to school
I mean it's like the difference one is
educated and not educated is not whether
or not they go to a specific place the
turtle it's whether or not they absorb
the information and when they study and
yeah you said you studied a thousand
hours before the film and 3,000 cents
that you're you're obviously educated
you understand what you're talking about
so so anyway you've got things factually
wrong about 312 so to the people
listening or watching do you really want
to put the interpretation of the data in
the hands of someone that just got so
many things wrong about b12 well he got
things wrong about your assertions about
me still stand that vegetarians and
vegans have much higher rates of b12
depletion or deficiency than omnivores
the bulk of there's no disagreement
these are vegetarians and anyone over
fifty and moat like the safest way and
you're now disputing the safest way to
get b12 is to take a supplement it's the
best way to surest way to get b12 but
it's not necessary for many people right
for people that can afford blood tests
which is know most of the world's like
you will live is sitting in in America
in a nice light air-conditioned room and
we know we've got cars and we drove here
we can afford to go to the doctor like
the best way to get b12 is to take a
supplement period and you're wrong if
you think otherwise if you can afford
you're short if you can afford if you
but we're gonna get 12 seconds to around
that's expensive right here's the thing
if you such a diet that gives you the
ample amount of b12 and you don't need
to supplement you don't need a
supplement sure you're saying is that
blood tests are expensive so you should
take an expensive supplement no they're
not expensive b12 no it's like if you
buy it in bulk like two dollars a year
but no I'm not yeah if you're buying
dollars a year you've got it but the
trick is you got to like you'd have to
split it with a bunch of people because
just like years worth of supply but
anyways so so no the argument is that
like I said and I've also shown it to
the world
I've also put two bucks here if I could
hook a lot of people up I've also shown
that in the study that you presented in
your eBook stated that like they weren't
absorbing it as well from an important
I'm not saying there's not b12 in animal
parts and also we have to remember one
last thing that the b12 that our people
are getting in animal products it was
supplemented in the first place in some
in in the vast majority fish not in
grass fed in the violence in the vast
majority of animal products the people
are eating b12 a supplement and so I'm
just saying the safest way to get b12 is
thicker supplement in the vast majority
is that true yeah you think the vast
majority of people are eating wild
caught fish and I don't know how many
animals are actual chicken all of the
chickens that's chickens chickens are
omnivores they're not fed omnivorous
diets right most part unless they're
free-range chickens if you give it you
ever seen a chicken [ __ ] up a mouse it's
pretty stunning yeah
yeah they're carnivorous little monsters
then chickens and when you get them and
you get those eggs and the eggs are like
a really dull yellow those are animals
reading grain only those are vegetarian
chickens that's not what they want to
eat what they want to eat his worms yeah
they're not living in the Narrows though
right in their natural state habitat we
don't need to have supplementation this
is sort of an argument against
vegetarian diets for chickens really
because no chickens aren't really
supposed to eat that way
yeah and feedlot for beef can we get to
protein cuz I sure miss protein every
flight no we're putting your time
cool also know that 12 you made some
excellent points and you definitely
cleared up what was what was
misrepresented right and it's really why
I really appreciate you having me on
because you guys did like a three-hour
debunk right and there was just a lot of
things weren't factually wrong and
there's more that I can point out okay
let's go I really appreciate having
[Applause]